[Music]
thanks for coming to my house guys
so you guys have been improving now for
how many months just over yeah yeah yeah
over a year okay and you've built up a
nice little rent to rent portfolio
financially independent
um so how did this all start like what
when was the moment when you were like
property investment that's the one so to
be honest with you um we kind of always
knew that we wanted to get into property
from where's like quite young
cousins cousins yeah okay we always used
to watch the property programs homes
with a hammer everything like that and
then um he kind of got to a stage where
he was like how are we actually going to
get into it yeah um so it's about 2020
wasn't it when 2020 towards the end of
2020 and he's like you know what we'll
do um we'll just see if we can
raise some money just save et cetera and
try to get into it that way um then it
was actually jordan to be honest um
we're both reading the book rich dad
poor dad um and then jordan actually
said
oh have you seen this guy on youtube
he's like
no i haven't seen him he's like some of
your leads because you need to watch
watch one of his vids and and like
tell me what tell me what you think so i
started watching your vids and then i
messaged him i was like this guy's a
genius i said we have to we have to try
and do something about this like
what you were saying was like resonating
with us like he was like he's speaking
to us so he's like you know what mainly
it was just sort of because we had been
looking at property we just didn't know
what entry point we could get into so
when we seen okay potentially we might
be able to get into it another way than
the conventional way
we was all over it just binge watching
trying to get through the video what's
the conventional way then what's the
what's the homes under the hammer
you know what what's the traditional way
i'd say really um
the way we was looking at it was we'll
both get into a job save up as much as
possible in this job to then be able to
go in and get maybe an auction property
or something like that but it wasn't
until we came across you and you showed
us how much of a stupid idea that was it
was like
now we're a bit screwed because that was
what we was banking on but now there's
another avenue i remember when we met as
well i remember when we were at the
crash course and you were like i've just
been made redundant
yeah i haven't really got much money to
invest i was like good
you know that one was actually crazy
because um i came up to you in one of
the breaks i said samuel look
love what you do and i love the course
um i'd really like to join but right now
i've just been made redundant i'm in a
bit of a situation what can i sort of do
and then you turned around to me and you
said
well this
i think it was 1995 how would you like
to pay
but in all honesty i think that sort of
commitment made us say you know what we
now need to commit it had to work we had
to make it work really any other option
which just kept propelling us forward
really yeah you know what as well when
people are wanting to do like deal
sourcing rent to rent flipping all that
kind of stuff when you haven't got much
money
and people come to me and say oh can you
train me can i tell you can i take you
out for a coffee and i kind of feel like
you know what if there's no skin in the
game you know what i'm saying so i could
have said to you oh yeah that's me i'll
train you i'll give you some advice but
it's like actually if you don't pay you
don't pay attention so when i said to
you look it's 195 so
how can you get the money and i know you
read rich dad poor dad which says never
say i can't afford that
instead so how can i
how can you get the money then bro how
can you just train so you guys did do
some advanced training what happened at
that point was the first course you did
with us on the online course first yeah
we've done the rent to an accelerator
online yeah um that enabled us to get
our first deal so we was like okay we've
now got to this level where we've got
one deal
we're struggling to get the second how
do we now elevate ourselves to get more
deals and right we just said we need the
education we've done the rentman
accelerator but that was only yeah we
didn't know exactly about hmos and
service accommodation so yeah we just
needed a bit more education really
even when we went to one viewing before
we kind of
thought of a it was just a hmo but
really looking back it was actually a
commentary center by the train station
it would have worked perfectly as an
essay but at that point in our journey
we hadn't been educated enough to notice
no it's that true okay we couldn't we
don't actually have to use it as a hmo
we can use it as a service accommodation
yeah so yeah at that point we kind of
just thought you know we need to
actually get educated now so how many
how many properties have you got now
we've got four rent to rent deals at the
moment four interim deals and you built
that up just in the last sort of 12
months
so you know the money is coming in
so so um how much on average is each
property kind of making so last month
throughout all of the properties we made
3800 clean profit
that was because we're sort of super
conservative with our figures yeah dead
concerns yeah just because um we'd
rather get a lot more than we was
expecting and get less than what we was
expected because you were expecting when
you first got those problems you were
saying to me like maybe 500 pounds a
month of each yeah which would be two
grand and it's almost double that
so it's a pleasant surprise
uh just outside birmingham so your
property area is where coventry yeah
leicester so we just thought um for our
patchwise we just keep within the
midlands um just so it's usually about
hours drive from the coventry
yeah and then sort of places yeah so
what i want to do in this interview is i
want to break down what you did how you
speak to landlords how you speak to
agents how you know whether a deal is
going to be good or not how to be
conservative on your numbers and how to
risk assess a deal the management side
of things and hopefully give the
audience that are listening some real
strong value in what to do it so let's
talk about your first deal
how did you find it and and and where
did it come from and what happened the
first deal so what we actually done we
sent out landlord letters we got these
sort of
database from online google just um
spent hours just importing it into excel
ready to sell mail merge and send it out
sent out i believe 200 letters and we
had about five to ten responses and
within those we then had one viewing um
he's a landlady she sort of had a hmo
the management side of it was sort of
getting on top of her a little bit
and also it was just a fact of she just
didn't have the time to be able to go
over to the property sort this out so
this is sorry to drop these landlords
then did you just rip this from the
council website exactly
so um yeah we just got some responses
from the letters back yeah went and had
a viewing um she was confident in what
we could provide um i think it was just
the way we sort of pitched to her and
sort of
proposed a deal yeah she was confident
landlord direct yeah exactly so she
contacted you what did the letter say
what did the
what was that he said
we just
put on our letters we just put about
five bullet points and we just list them
we just said on there that um we can
provide a hassle-free approach for you
and we can literally take and give you a
guaranteed rent every month
and then you just have free time so we
kind of just made it three three to four
bullet points just so it's quite simple
and kind of introduced the concept of
like obviously we we
then take it on um and then provide
yourself with the guaranteed rent etc
and then
we because we also put in the fact that
it's just coming out of colvid um so we
tried to just use that as an advantage
because tenants were low in the area at
the time so um to the landlord it seemed
like maybe we can't get tenants i think
they were a bit panicking about that
yeah which allowed us to sort of say we
can still find tenants and things like
that grant cardone says never miss a
good crisis
you know i'm saying so if there's yeah
if there's problems if there's a crash
or if there's uh a lock now whenever
there's a whatever there's problems that
means there's opportunities because
people are worried people are concerned
you can find a solution and bring in a
business proposition so okay so you
begin get this letter out you say these
are the advantages basically to rent to
rent right i can give you a guaranteed
rent um we can fix the price the price
we'll then take care of finding the
tenants and we'll keep the profit
um that we make so it's risk-free for
the landlady so what did she say
yeah she was pretty happy with it um one
thing that actually kind of worked in
our favor when we went for the viewing
um there's eight bedrooms in the hate uh
in the hmo and so there was bedroom four
right at the back uh so she knew that
the tenant wasn't there but when we
actually went for the viewing the room
was trashed like it was
probably one of the worst rooms we've
ever seen
to her knowledge she thought that
somebody was still living they was in
okay condition but clearly the the
laying agents that had it wasn't really
doing the best job so for us it kind of
worked in our favor because she's
probably thinking well these are some
new guys what clearly what i was doing
before wasn't working so right she's
thinking i can't bother with all this
yes the hassle yeah how did you get
around like referencing and all that did
you that one was it was actually crazy
because it was direct to landlord we
didn't have to sort of do any references
no deposit anything like that so um we
sort of just went away for after the
viewing sort of worked out the figures
that would stack for us and we made her
offer she was she was actually happy
with the offer and we offered her 2037
pounds a month why specifically somebody
gave us a tip previously
they just said to us if
you've got a specific number it just
seems like it's more calculated so we i
believe we factored in 2050 and it
stacked for us so we said well we may as
well knock 12 13 quid off and it looks a
bit more um solid
because it kind of makes people think
like oh wow there's a reason you put
that that must be at the maximum there's
no negotiations here whereas if you say
two grand they might go oh call it 225.
yeah
2037 pounds that's it you know so okay
so that went well and um we just
negotiated with the landlord this was in
april last year yeah so um she's about a
year ago now yeah she said that tenants
are actually in the property until
august so we wouldn't be able to take it
on until then but in the meantime we
said okay we'll take the property on
from august um would we be able to use
the keys and once once per week be able
to get some tenants in so now we've
already agreed we've got a two week
rent free period in august to take us to
september and then between that time
from april to september we can already
get our tenants in before we've paid a
penny so it's like a total no money down
deal yeah exactly wow you know what's
really funny some people say i can't do
your insurance because i can't pass the
reference in well on this occasion there
was no referencing because she trusted
you and warmed to you as people and
business people number two angered the
money well in this occasion you didn't
need any money
so it was a perfect deal yeah it was um
so when we took it on um the contract
started in september so by at that point
we had already pretty much filled all
the rooms there was just one left which
come in at the end of september so um it
actually really worked quite well
because from the get go it was fully
occupied
and we didn't even have to really worry
about oh we
haven't got one tenant or whatever
literally straight away full tenants how
much profit is that how much profit you
getting from that deal well that one
it's a bit crazy because we still had to
put 3 000 into that deal so um at this
point we'd put our money on education
and setting up the company we now have
not enough money to put into this deal
what did you need the money for like
furniture and stuff yeah
exactly
exactly yeah but you spent it all on my
courses exactly so now we thought of um
one of the courses that we had done was
joint venture and raising finance so we
went out found an armchair investor who
would put the money in for us to three
thousand pound we give them a fixed 10
percent return and then from there
that's how we sort of go
and so it was no money now we didn't
have to put anything in
i've got like say 10 grand 20 grand 30
grand and they hold on to it and they
think i want to use this to invest and
it's like actually unless you've got a
million pounds
you're not really going to be able to
make a massive amount of money by
investing a small amount of money really
what you need to do is in my opinion is
invest that in yourself
and then you know how to raise finance
on an unlimited amount of deals yeah so
that's kind of what you guys did so
respect on that so okay that was your
first deal how much you renting that out
for in total uh
3 600.
so you're playing the landlady 2037.
you're writing it for three six yeah and
then obviously you've got to pay bills
yeah sort of about 600 pounding um
utility bills at the moment sorry about
that since yeah over the last few years
you're left with what about what like
800 900 quid profit yeah yeah
i have to be paid everything yeah it's
probably about eight nine eight cents
yeah and then what about your second
deal the well the second deal we
actually contacted the landlord um on
open rent okay so um they had an
apartment on open road so we've
contacted them just dropped the message
saying um hi look we can offer you a
hassle-free approach for hands-off
approach and some guaranteed rent and
they then got back to us and was like oh
that's brilliant that's great um when
can you view sort of thing so we we then
went down for a viewing this was in
december
i'm sorry to interrupt but open is like
right move yeah but just landlords
direct yeah and and the best thing we
found out like with open rent um was the
fact that because it's so direct um you
kind of cut out any any other parts so
the rapport can be built straight away
so even prior to the viewing you the
rapport has already been built up with
the landlord so when we got there this
was december last year
christmas eve
yeah
yeah it was christmas eve
so he's working all the way up until
christmas and went there and i've spoke
to the landlord he was absolutely
amazing he loved what was looking to do
with them the property which was um
service accommodation right um so
as we finished the viewing for the first
one uh because the rapport was already
built up he literally said to us he's
got i've got another one in this
building it hasn't been listed yet do
you want to have a look at it so he's
like you know what
while we're here
exactly so um we've gone upstairs and
we've had a look at this one and it was
literally on the same level as the one
we just seen um if not better and then
he was like um
how much would you want for this one so
we kind of made him our offer for this
the following day
and um he accepted both of the offers um
for both for the apartment so we went
out to find one but actually ended up
getting to
and it shows as well you know the person
that that sees the most people you know
you just gotta get out there book
viewings and on the training that's what
we're very much about isn't it just pick
up the phone get viewings because you
don't know from one viewing how many
ripple effects or domino effects that
could yes just to touch on that point um
we was actually at the training and um
i remember was it generating leads i
believe it was to generate as many leads
or viewings as possible and i teamed up
with another person called aaron and i
believe this is the point where it
changed for me because
i was sort of calling up agents trying
to speak to them and
effectively i was factoring in a bit too
much due diligence before i've even made
the call i'm thinking will this work
will the figures work how much can i pay
whereas if i just pick up the phone make
the call make the viewing
figure out the rest later so that's what
a big tip was for us from just yeah how
many how many um viewings did you manage
to get on the programme i believe
between me and aaron was it five
viewings we had something like that and
then we were sort of up on stage and uh
everyone was cheering for us so it was
great
on the program on that program we only
managed to get one view in okay everyone
wants to get the one yeah and that
that's the thing though it's about
action isn't it exactly you can over
people can overthink things or they
think they've got to get um you know
loads of due diligence and spend hours
and hours and hours before they pick up
the phone you just gotta pick up the
phone man
how's the management side been you've
got obviously you've got hmos you've got
service accommodation totally got four
four properties making a really good
income from them how how difficult is it
because i know you guys are quite
hands-on
the management is that like a nightmare
is it what
to be fair i feel like the management
hasn't it has been
a little bit difficult at
times especially now when you get to the
point of that you got four it's just
managing all of them but we've kind of
just broken it down and we the way we've
systemized stuff and with the key safes
at the properties um also we use um
cleaners like the power team that we've
got is brilliant especially in the
coventry area as well and that's why
you've stuck to commentary yeah because
we've the power team that we have
they're literally on call um we had a
little issue with the tenant they had a
blockage in their toilet
we called the plumber the next day he
was out there fixed it so we have really
got a hands-on team at the moment i
think for us um
because we took on one hmo and then we
sort of took on three service
accommodations
quite close so we went from just
managing one property to now managing
four and um the change between hmo and
sa um
it was a bit overwhelming at first just
in terms of we hadn't got the correct
power team in place and things like that
so going from
doing a lot of things ourselves to now
being able to pass a few things on sort
of as general said systemize outsource
things it sort of brought back our time
now to be able to focus on more deals
now you've systemized it how many hours
a week roughly would you say you spend
managing your four properties
between about 10 hours 10 to 15 hours a
week yeah okay i'll tell you about that
yeah so it's kind of like part time
you've systemized it but still if you're
making like 3 800 a month it's not bad
and you're still new-ish so there's
you'll probably systemize it more as we
go on were there any points over the
last year or two where you wanted to
quit
in all honesty i wouldn't say there's
i wouldn't say i've had a time where i
wanted to quit but i've had times where
i found it very difficult just in terms
of as i was saying earlier we took on
one hmo and then we took on three essays
so when we took on the free essays
it was just a lot in terms of
the finances that had to be put into
those just as free the incas things like
that so um because you guys were
starting on a shoestring budget as well
it's not like you had 25 grand behind
you to start the business and you also
invested in your education you got all
these deals rent needs to be paid i can
see that it would be stressful so um but
we we just said we're way too far in
we've got things that we want to
accomplish in life we've got we know
exactly where we want to sort of go yeah
so
um put in so far as well like the
results of showing like
it's it's easy to look back and think ah
the mistakes that we've made but at the
end of the day how far we've come since
the point we started has just been that
great why why can't you keep going
forward sort of thing but in the tough
times i think it was more the fact that
it's just
we not know where we want to go to so
we're too we can't stop we're we're
already in the middle of the ocean
i think we i think we prep our students
pretty well for the tough times we say
the importance of persistence it's going
to get hard did you have any like
friends or anything or
trying to put you off any of that um no
to be honest our friendship group is
actually pretty supportive um yeah we
have young entrepreneur entrepreneurs in
our friendship group as well um so it's
it's good to see how
they're doing their side of the business
and how and he's kind of just looking at
each other's journeys and even though
we're in different aspects of business
right it's that you can still have that
same conversation about skating not
leveling up how how different strategies
help marketing wise it says
unfortunately because a lot of people a
lot of young guys starting out they've
got their mom and their this person and
their aunties being like be careful be
careful trying to stop them and then
when you get your first bit of money
then it's like then it's like okay well
we'll see
then you start making three thousand
eight hundred it's like money isn't
everything
we waited for that one we was pretty
lucky just because our friends family
was so supportive um just a quick
example um we went out to watch um sort
of football one night and obviously our
mums and sisters so they're saying to us
oh you can't be going out you're getting
complacent you need to focus all the
time oh they're more unto us than what
we are um
shout out to your mom exactly that's
amazing what would you say the biggest
like you've obviously learned a lot from
from not just the training but also from
actually doing it you know so what would
you say the biggest lessons from
actually doing it on the road what would
you say the biggest lessons have been i
would say the biggest lesson that you
can take is action because
regard
let's just say for example when we went
to leicester one time um we both had a
day off and was just like you know what
what are we doing we said we'll go
leicester we'll just go into some um
letting agents have a conversation with
them and at first i was like
shall we do he's like you know what yeah
we haven't been out of the company so
let's do it so we drove down leicester
went into
it was about five
five six letting agents um and that's
actually where the leicester essay come
from wow just foundation
yeah
so you've used open rent you've used
scraping the council website you've used
all the and there's so many ways to get
deals there's not just one way it's
about doing everything yeah some people
you know send out ten letters you sent
out two hundred and you had five or ten
so you only had like five percent yeah
but you only needed the one to get right
some people send send ten letters they
don't get a single response and they got
item work yeah yeah it's the same when
we started off making calls i remember
um when we first done the rent to rent
accelerator online um the the feeling of
first picking up the course is called an
agent i was just thinking i think i
gotta know and i was like oh
i know again i'm thinking you know what
just like try and stick to it yeah keep
getting those but at some point you do
you pick it up and and something changes
it just clicks and i think that's down
to the education really like once you
get educated and you know what you guys
say saying you know the ways you've got
to go about it like like you said your
toolbox
it's hard it's hard not to um yeah
prospering what would you say the
differences between the online training
and the in person
i'd say the online training we got the
technical fundamentals but
it well it allowed us to get a deal at
the end of the day however when we went
to the live in person just the
atmosphere the energy the environment
yeah just bouncing ideas off of people
when you're on stage um i remember the
first day i think um did it start at 10
or 11 but it went to about nine ten at
night usually if that was a normal job
or even another education course you're
sort of tired yeah you're right you're
ready to sort of chao but um at that
course the energy the change of states
just being able to be around like-minded
people it's just amazing yeah yeah it's
amazing yeah the energy in the room is
brilliant
you just you just get immersed in it and
then you get carried away
next thing you know you're like oh my
gosh i got five viewings
in a day
yeah you know what as well i think um
environment's so important
not just what you know but also who you
know and i think getting yourself
uncomfortable being in rooms with people
that are doing deals that can pull you
up so important it's so important so
what's next for you guys then because
when i asked you to come on winners on a
wednesday you're a bit like unsure
i think that was purely because um
obviously when we started out
from where we've come to to where we've
got to i think
we need to realize that we've sort of
seen
a little bit of success it's nowhere
near where we want to get to but we need
to realize yeah we have seen a little
bit of success now um celebrate that and
let me always say when people get to the
2 000 pounds a month mark when our
students hit that two grand a month mark
that's when it's like come on the show
because some people oh wait till i get
10 grand a month but then it's like well
hang on a minute you might even become
unrelatable by that point or you might
forget the hardships of the beginning
yeah it's about what you do in the
beginning
you know so and and for me
you know people can only hear my story
over and over and it's like when people
hear different perspectives from
different walks of life you guys are
from dudley um you know it's just it
will inspire people in different ways so
it's been it's been such a pleasure
working with you guys deserve every
everything you've achieved appreciate it
thank you
what would you say your final words of
wisdom would be for someone watching the
video
wants to get in property what would you
say
their first step needs to be personally
personally i'd say um you need
to be an action taker just because
if you're just a thinker or doer i think
i'd you you won't get anything done yeah
so be an action taker and also just have
a real strong reason of why you're doing
this and what you want to achieve
because that would just keep you going
what's your reason
my reasons are um i've sort of seen when
my mom and my sister have come from and
what they've done to
make ends meet so for me i've just been
ingrained in sort of
being able to just elevate my family
being able to just help other people out
so we've sort of spoke about it in time
we want to be able to just help other
people and that's we want to be able to
be in a position of giving not just
receiving right so um
you guys have got big hearts man yeah so
that's i love that how about yourself
final words of wisdom my final words of
wisdom would be just to forget what
anybody else says if anybody has any
knowledge or whatever follow your own
mind and make sure that you just do it
um and just make sure that you believe
in yourself regardless of anything and
you can get through any situation just
keep being persistent guys big respect
big love
keep up the great work
folks i hope you've enjoyed that i hope
you learned a lot i hope you're feeling
inspired if you want to come down to the
property investors crash course like
these guys did meet me get in a good
environment then there are free tickets
available limited spaces so get booked
now i'll leave a link in the description
i've done over a hundred interviews like
this with my students i think it's about
140 maybe 160 or odd you can check out
the entire playlist right here if you
need some motivation get booked on the
property investors crash course here
subscribe and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you